let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
lee greenwood
all the country music singers
john cornyn
even
ken paxton that piece of [ __ ]
won't even go to the nra convention the
gunless gathering the gunless gathering
that they're going to have this evening
in texas where they're going to cheer
cheer 19 slaughtered children in uvalde
and they're going to cheer their right
their right to make sure that they can
go into schools
and slaughter our children that's their
constitutional right
fun fact
fun fact
in the united states of america
we have had
a ban
on assault weapons
that's a fun fact isn't it
it's happened before you know what you
know you know i it even [ __ ] worked
but forget about things that work in
this country
we gotta talk about things like back
doors mental illness
we gotta wonder we gotta wonder if the
police officers
that are forming swat swat teams to
protect our children
because gun nuts
guys with gun boners
have to make sure they have the
the best weapons of war
to kill our children so we have to train
pay good money to train a swat team
to wait for another swat team or stand
outside and
guard the school to make sure parents
don't get in
while the while the second amendment
freedom fighter on the inside mows down
and tears apart children with an assault
rifle
oh you think
you thought you thought oh well tony
will let up on this
he'll let up on just like oh he'll let
up he'll let up on them taking the right
away from women
to the to the
autonomy of their bodies [ __ ] no
i'm not gonna [ __ ] sugarcoat it
either i don't give a [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] murdering children
yes the politicians in this country you
dumb [ __ ] who are voting for
republicans those politicians are
killing children
they're standing outside of buildings
where dozens of children have been
slaughtered talking about the back door
they're gonna go to a [ __ ] gunless
conference
think about this the nra the national
rifle association the [ __ ]
organization that lobbies
raises money threatens these republican
politicians to make sure that there is
the right to carry and kill anyone in
this country with an assault weapon
because they have to sell those weapons
to be profitable
won't even [ __ ] allow a firearm
inside their [ __ ] little meeting
you know why they won't allow a firearm
inside a [ __ ] nra convention
because they're afraid of getting
[ __ ] gunned down
but they want to give teachers guns
let's get what [ __ ]
i said the other day [ __ ] the teachers
just give the students guns why not
the manufacturers would love that
the gun manufacturers would love to
manufacture a second grade sized [ __ ]
ar-15 they'd [ __ ] love that why not
high capacity magazines and all
miniature ones of course
i mean it would be great for the
christmas card right lauren bobert you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] talking about how
betto somehow is offensive and oh my god
it's the most egregious thing because he
interrupted the nra presser the other
day where greg abbott and dan patrick
were just repeating what they were told
to repeat by the nra
and she's gonna go to a march for life
or some [ __ ] i don't know we're gonna
watch it patriot takes released a video
we're gonna watch that [ __ ] today at
some point
it's [ __ ] dumbass
johnson talking about faith and morals
rod johnson's gonna preach to us
the country about faith and morals
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
ron johnson
what are you trying to out ted cruz ted
cruz
come on
give me a [ __ ] break
faith and morals
take your faith in your morals ron
johnson and stick them up your [ __ ]
ass
folks
we need to make politics out of this
i keep saying all democrats are going to
make politics out of this that's all it
is they're just politics you god damn
right we are
why not wha
what other [ __ ] options do you have
you tried everything else
it's been 10 years since sandy hook
where a gunman went in and [ __ ] cut
up children little bitty babies with a
gun
and the country pled please begged got
on their [ __ ] knees they put out all
kinds of [ __ ] videos with hollywood
elites saying it
enough of this enough of the soft-handed
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] we need to politically
punch them in the [ __ ] mouth it is
enough of this [ __ ]
absolutely enough
they want to take away
your children's [ __ ] right to learn
by taking away math
they want to take your consent away from
your children especially especially if
that children
has questions about their identity they
want to take your [ __ ] consent away
they want to make sure they have the
consent to marry your children in some
states
they want to tell you what the [ __ ] you
can and cannot do with your body your
uterus what what decisions you can make
with you and your doctor
they want to tell you what kind of
[ __ ] sex you're gonna have i read a
[ __ ] article last night in oklahoma
in the state of oklahoma there's some
[ __ ] crazy loon wakkadoo
i think it's oklahoma it doesn't really
matter where it's at doesn't matter
where these [ __ ] are at anymore some
wackadoo wants to declare
life begins before conception i told you
i [ __ ] told you doubt me i said they
will say that life begins with a boner i
said it i'll go pull the [ __ ] clip
they want to tell you how and who and
when and where you can even [ __ ]
they want to regulate all of it
they want gut big government everywhere
besides the safety of your children
besides the safety of people in a
grocery store or church
or a community gathering or concert
a bar a nightclub a restaurant nah nope
nope
gun manufacturers definitely have the
freedom to make sure
that they sell guns and flood the
streets with guns
that absolutely [ __ ]
tear apart rip apart
americans children
fathers mothers grandmothers
black white latino anywhere in between
they don't give a [ __ ]
and they'll pay anything they'll pay
anything for the ability to sell these
weapons on the street
hell they're even promoting to buy these
guns for they won't buy teachers erasers
and pencils
but they'll buy him a [ __ ] handgun
oh this uvaldi police thing is getting
hairier by the day as well
by the hour by the minute they can't
answer the [ __ ] questions and any
time any time they answer a [ __ ]
question it's a different [ __ ] answer
than what they had
sometimes in the same goddamn sentence
you would think that a [ __ ] that
comes out
to do a press conference
on a mass shooting where 19 little kids
and two teachers were killed at an
elementary school in their [ __ ] town
that they would at least have the
[ __ ] timeline together they would at
least have some facts gathered up
i don't know what happened
between the time that he parked his car
they keep saying he wrecked his truck
i've seen the pictures that truck is not
wrecked it's parked in the ditch
the time he parked his truck and walked
into that school they can't account for
that time they have no [ __ ] idea no
[ __ ] clue couldn't [ __ ] tell you
what the hell was going on
and then it's almost a goddamn hour
before they enter the school why can't
they say why why
what why in the [ __ ] can't they tell us
why it was an hour
were they talking to him through the
window were they engaging with him
through the window
and apparently they were absolutely
terrified
the swat team who is trained
they're trained they bragged about
training in schools the uvalde swat team
we're terrified
that this person had a gun
well isn't that [ __ ] convenient
isn't that [ __ ] convenient greg
abbott don't you see why we're saying
the blood is on your hands you [ __ ]
idiot
ted cruz john cornyn ken paxton dan
patrick you pathetic [ __ ] cowards
that's why we're saying blood's on your
hands
even the cops know that the machine gun
that the [ __ ] had was designed
to kill them
oh well you you can use it for deer
hunting we got to protect our tvs and
our homes what happens if someone breaks
in my house and steals my your tv is a
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] no one is coming
in your house to get your [ __ ] tv you
goddamn dummy
you do not need a firearm to protect the
garbage that is in your house it is
trash no one wants it
these weapons are designed
designed
to kill
tactical
victims people who have body armor on
people who have long guns
that's what these
weapons are designed to do
they're not designed for the bullet to
enter your body and exit immediately
they're designed to rip apart your limbs
to destroy your [ __ ] head
shred your flesh
that's the design
the manufacturers are designing these
guns
to absolutely
slaughter your children
slaughter your neighbor
slaughter your spouse
slaughter your your brother your sister
your mom your dad your grandmother
in a school
in a grocery store in a church
at a community event
and we
we the people in this country are
[ __ ] letting them do it
oh but tony we can't do anything we
already vote we already vote
so you're telling me
that in texas
there's no other option in texas
no other option
there's not enough unregistered voters
there's not enough people who set this
one out
bull
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you are fooling yourself you are doing
the things that liberals and democrats
and moderates and independents have done
for years they've already won
they've already won
why try [ __ ] that [ __ ] it is up to us
it is up to us
to make sure that we our children have
the freedom to live and learn
that women have the right to their own
[ __ ] body
that we don't have to walk around
wondering
if they're gonna jail us because we're
[ __ ] the wrong way that they don't
want us to [ __ ]
that you're not a felon because you use
birth control
that's where they're going
it's where they're
going and this gun control
or lack thereof
absolute lack thereof of any kind of
sensible [ __ ]
gun safety and gun measures
is designed to perpetuate their fascism
that's the design
to scare you to terrify you well [ __ ]
that
[ __ ] i'm i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
stand outside of school
and let children get slaughtered on the
inside if i can do something about it i
would and i tell you i've seen the
videos and we played them here
of those law enforcement officers
stopping those parents some tasing them
some subduing some handcuffing them i
guess
stopping them from going in that school
you'd have to kill me [ __ ] you'd
have to kill me
the video shows
that the police
were using their weapons to intimidate
the parents outside while they stood and
waited
for another swat team
because they were too scared to go in
and get shot
greg abbott put those law enforcement
officers and those parents in that
position greg abbott did
one guy signed that bill one
[ __ ]
to where that kid could get guns
the way he did legally
and carry those guns
into that school and he wants he wants
he wants more guns
jesus christ he was he was tweeting it
oh we need more guns in california
california it's a competition of how
many guns
greg abbott caused
the mass shooting in uvalde texas
he caused it
and all the [ __ ] that came up
with that stupid [ __ ] ass bill
and he still he's not gonna go to the
nra convention because that that would
that would look bad
that would look bad if he spoke at it in
person so he's gonna film something oh
well
thank goodness
thank goodness
a real [ __ ] man a real [ __ ] man
someone who actually
stood up for their families stood up for
their community
would tell the nra to go [ __ ] themselves
he would get on national tv right now
and he would say i made a [ __ ]
mistake
i made a [ __ ] mistake
right now but he's not because he's a
[ __ ] coward
they're [ __ ] cowards
because if he does that you know what
the nra is going to tell him well we're
going to vote you out [ __ ]
roll on down the road greg abbott
because you're out
that's why he's still phoning in a
message
they got him by the shortened curlies
folks probably the ones that he's trying
to tan
we had to listen to [ __ ] ted cruz's
fake ass outrage
fake ass outrage about some doors get
the [ __ ] out of here with that door [ __ ]
we need to turn we need to turn our
schools into prisons
that's what we need to do we need to
lock them kids in those [ __ ] schools
because we need our guns pew pew pew pew
pew pew pew pew
you are a bunch of dumb [ __ ] if
you think this country wants to send
their sk their kids their grandkids to
prisons so you can own you some [ __ ]
guns you are a dumb [ __ ] and
anyone out here there who believes that
dumb [ __ ] you are [ __ ] fooling
yourself
that you think the majority of people in
this country want to turn our
elementaries our our middle schools our
high schools our college campuses into
prisons so you can own you some [ __ ]
guns that would kill those people inside
those buildings you are a dumb
[ __ ] pluck your head out of your
[ __ ] ass take your ar-15s that you
bought
because you think you're some kind of
[ __ ] tough guy take them up to law
enforcement and tell them to melt those
[ __ ] down
that's what you can do today
if you bought into this delusion that
somehow it's cool to own a [ __ ]
assault rifle
and you feel a shame that the weapon
that you have in your closet on your gun
safe
is being used to murder [ __ ] children
in this country take that [ __ ]
down to law enforcement right now and
tell them to melt that [ __ ] down
all of it the magazines
the weapons [ __ ] take all your weapons
down there handguns and all
if you want to do something
i mean you may you may you may still
believe in the second amendment and
people owning guns
but by god
there has to be a moment in this country
other countries have done it
they've done it
they watch people innocent people get
slaughtered because they're not doing
anything
and they go you know we should probably
do something about that scotland
australia
we've done it here in the united states
of america ronald reagan their [ __ ]
hero
was the one who pulled the assault
weapons ban over the goddamn line
in congress when it passed in 1992
they're [ __ ] their first god
now that they've replaced
reagan jesus with their orange mussolini
jesus their nra jesus
we've done it here
we have done that here in the united
states
it's not new
it's not some kind of [ __ ] great
grand idea
we did
it the only problem was is we didn't
make it permanent
and then we voted in a republican
and we continued to vote in republicans
and the nra bought and paid for those
republicans
because it's i mean it's easy to buy
republicans
ah it's easy
[ __ ] easy they have no principles
no morals no faith why do you think ron
johnson say we need more faith in morals
because he has none
it's all projection all of it
the whole lot of it
ron johnson
acts like he's some kind of [ __ ]
patriot he went to russia
to capitulate to putin on the 4th of
july he celebrated independence day
american independence day with the
murderous dictator vladimir putin what
did they [ __ ] watch fireworks and eat
hot dogs and hamburgers together
while they made out after the
festivities
in the back of a pickup truck
i don't know what happened
i'm just
snowballing here
i would imagine that ron johnson would
love
to go to a fourth of july festival with
vladimir putin holding hands eating hot
dogs and hamburgers and then make out
with him on a blanket in the back of a
pickup truck while he watched the
fireworks go off i would imagine
that's something he would like to do
sounds like it looks like it the
evidence points to it
i don't know
you decide
you [ __ ] figure it out
this isn't going away this weekend this
weekend there's gonna be a mass shooting
folks
this [ __ ] weekend
more americans slaughtered
god knows what state who knows
it could be a state with very strict gun
laws because
they can drive to texas and buy whatever
weapon they want
they can go to texas and get whatever
weapon they want hell the news has
proven it this 18 year old is able to
buy two [ __ ] weapons
no questions asked
and that's why ted cruz is still going
to speak at the nra that's why donald
trump is still going to speak at the nra
that's why the nra is still having their
event even though all their
entertainment's cancelled
because it is really gross even lee
greenwood that whack-a-doo
even lee greenwood
was like eh that's a little too much a
little too much i'm not gonna go sing
god bless america
at the bloodstained nra gunless
gathering
probably not a good idea
even lee greenwood wouldn't have any of
that [ __ ] dan patrick
and ken paxton are like no no ken paxton
that vile piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you
remember ken paxton
he's the one that's suggesting we should
give guns to teachers he's the one under
federal indictment for fraud
and he's still the attorney general and
they elected him in the primary to be
the candidate on the republican ticket
do you need any more [ __ ] evidence
what more evidence do you need
about these pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's not complicated it's not [ __ ]
rocket science
it really is easy to understand and my
hope is my hope is in texas
that there's plenty of reasonable people
that understand the stakes here are not
about democrat and republican and
socialism and conservatism
it's about common [ __ ] sense
democracy
common [ __ ] sense democracy this is
getting really [ __ ] stupid
life begins at boners they want to ban
condoms
they want to make sure women are felons
if they cross a border
they want to make sure that 18 year old
teenagers can buy guns and go slaughter
children in a now at the local
elementary school
carry guns two hours to a grocery store
in a predominantly black community to
mow down black people they want to make
sure
that that is america
well i'm here to tell you that's not the
[ __ ] that's not america that's not
america and we do not have to [ __ ]
put up with it we do not
republican democrat conservative liberal
it's enough of that [ __ ] enough of
that [ __ ] common sense democracy
[ __ ] me why the [ __ ] can't we [ __ ]
get our heads on straight
stop the delusion stop the bs
it's time
it appears there's a press conference
going on we're gonna try to pull that
press conference up if we can
now let's take a quick break as soon as
we come back i'll bring my co-host gabe
sanchez and maybe we'll get this press
conference going stick around we'll be
right back after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ] up
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we are trying to get some
live feed i think i found it here
[Music]
of the
vaulty
press conference
um apparently there's some crazy stuff
going on good morning gabe now we're
gonna try to
we're gonna try to get uh see if we can
pull this up here um looks like it's
live right now
there's arrival and seeing what they did
and
and looked at those sentences
was
if i thought it would help out apologize
okay but hey but hey hey but let me let
me say this hey let me let me say this
when you go back to the timeline again i
want to go back and am not defending
anything but you go back to the timeline
there was a barrage hundreds of rounds
were pumped in in four minutes okay into
those two classrooms
then anything else any firing afterwards
was sporadic and it was at the door so
the belief is that there may not be
anybody living anymore and that the
subject is now trying to keep law
enforcement at bay or entice them to
come in
suicide by content i understand that
i've recorded that
this is a different um officer than was
giving the press conferences yesterday
well i might answer the first one but
the y on the second one i don't have the
first one that each door can lock from
the inside and where both doors were
locked okay from the inside so the
subject when he went in
he locked the door he came out one time
into the hallway went back in and locked
the door because at the time that the
officers went in both doors were locked
they got a key from the janitor and used
it
this whole thing man [ __ ]
their timeline is jacked up in these i
don't have that answer we're looking at
right now they won't answer anything on
the timeline
i don't know man i have this i was
telling you yesterday i was feeling like
one of these officers [ __ ] up inside
the school and now they're trying to
cover up for it well something happened
i don't know if they fired a weapon and
it hit someone or i i don't know there's
that there's the part where law
enforcement was going in to get their
own children i i don't know what what
the hell they're trying to hide but
there is something that is [ __ ] up and
yeah it seems they're trying to hide
something
they've changed their story this officer
can't even keep he can't even keep his
composure here he's in he's in very bad
shape whoever this is speaking what
about the parents
those children
they forget about me and one time they
were our officers and stuff like that we
take an oath to uphold the law and
protect people at any time but did you
know why it happened and if we can do
better next time we know why it happened
they call it like it is it's tragic
quite frankly i mean
it's not traffic tragic it's predictable
at this point
it is predictable and it
is pathetic
you know on the 24th
okay
good
and we're looking at other people
absolutely anybody's been in contact
we're looking at anything links
associations you know people may that
may have known something and uh and will
continue may may be involved in some
chat room game gaming along with them so
there's nobody that we're not going to
talk to and look at and then certainly i
can assure you that the district
attorney is very proactive and very
guarantee you i guarantee you they won't
look at the gun laws
the evidence no brain tour that's
something chat rooms and video games
keep the [ __ ] real ones what happened
during those 12 minutes doubt that
she'll take care of businesses like she
did back in 2018 when we had two
juveniles
plot a capital murder at the school
every single time they're always like
we're gonna we're gonna prevent it next
time we're gonna get in front of it next
time next time next time next time next
time that's what better was saying
outside the press conference that that's
all nonsense uh yes
you know i i can't tell you that was
with certainty but more than one
survived how many children
sorry what
i'll go backwards and right over here
i'll move over here
something shot into these windows right
here
it's hard to tell him to hear what he's
saying he's going through the map here
everyone's been saying that we need to
back this up
the other fear that i have is they
chased him into the building potentially
well that you know there's the 10
minutes between where he parks his
vehicle because they keep saying wrecked
but i've seen the pictures of it it's
not wrecked it's it he drove it into the
ditch he parked it
it's hard to it's hard to hear him here
yeah here we go maybe he'll maybe he'll
re-speak what he said because
from the tackles
and everything in terms of looking
backwards okay and the
and certainly one of the things is
what was the access
at 111 and 112 in that regard and it uh
and also you know there's other access
points as well
[Applause]
right there hold on
let me see what's happening one thing
one thing one thing one thing i didn't
point out okay
is that when we we've got him going into
these rooms
right here is the jack and jill restroom
between
so not unlike santa fe
these the classrooms are separated but
they're really connected so you can move
back and forth between those two
classrooms
that question will be answered
but i don't have the i'm not going to
share the information we have right now
but because i don't have i don't have
the detailed interview right now
answer right there
here we go there we go not that i'm
aware of no sir
he answered no and it was it was
reported the other day from an officer
that they were
i know for two
for certain did and those two did not
it died line is oh like we reported what
happened because that back door was
propped open yep it wasn't supposed to
be proper i told you it's supposed to be
[ __ ] locked and certainly the teacher
that went back for her cell phone it
propped it open again so that was an
access point that the subject used
go ahead go ahead
hold on
no [ __ ] ton of high inside mistakes
well first of all we welcome the fbi
there's a reason why there's the fbi
special agent in charge behind me right
now they play a vital role and again
this is about finding facts and
reporting facts as quick as we can oh is
it really about trying to defend or it's
not about trying to assess or even be
you [ __ ] full of [ __ ]
this guy doesn't look at your guns as a
problem and says it was the teacher's
fault she propped the door open to go
get her cell phone in her car
the chief of police the consolidated
independent school district is the
incident commander
it's his school he's the chief of police
okay
yeah again that's i'm not going to
discuss disciplinary there's an ongoing
criminal investigations ongoing criminal
investigation
why is there an ongoing criminal
investigation into who yeah you know i'm
not going to get into
that
all right
yeah man
the chief of police the consulate
infants just ask who made the decision
to not breach the classroom i want to go
back and say you know he was convinced
at the time that the no more threat to
the children and that the subject was
barricaded and that they had time with
the kids in the room proper equipment to
go in the subject already had hit you
know three officers and uh hit two
officers and i didn't answer the final
question a third a border patrol agent
was grazed as well but no one was sir no
police officer was seriously injured
because they are all [ __ ] hiding
yes
yes
he shot and i went through the timeline
before where he continued to shoot
periodically sporadically
the last yeah the last i think already
gave you the timeline i went i'm sure i
went through it but the
the last time that the shot right before
the the entry
okay was
was he shot at 12 21. so
no not at the children
we don't know yet we believe it was at
the door that's what he fired at
what
[Music]
agents arrived they had they had three
ballistic shields
he didn't know
[Music]
first of all hey texas embraces and
teaches okay the active shooter doctrine
the active duty doctrine as long as
there's kids as long as there's
someone's firing you go to the gun you
find them you neutralize them period and
there's almost like you wouldn't need
nuances with going transitioning
subjects
also transitioning to a hostage
situation
and of course that the decision at the
scene was that this is still a
barricaded subject that did not go back
to an active situation
well because i'm here to address the
latest timeline and facts that we know
here's what you're saying there's some
criminal [ __ ] going on
reach out to them because the guy who
was talking yesterday
he couldn't get the facts straight
because they're hiding something hold on
that's a good question
you've now been on the scene for several
days
what exactly is your role in this
investigation and hearing all this given
that the
okay now i think we're going to hear
from the fbi here
this is something that requires an
independent investigation yeah get those
cops out of there
thank you for the question so my name is
oliver rich i'm the special agent in
charge of the san antonio division um
first i want to say i understand there
are a lot of questions and a lot of
frustration in the public in our heart
goes out to the families and the victims
in this tragedy i'm sure
i will say our role here remains the
same we are here to assist in this
investigation to provide the support to
the community to the best of our ability
we've had 200 people here for over four
days we have people working all across
the country to support this community
and to support this investigation
we are continuing in that vein we have
victim specialists here working with
people in the community and we will
continue to do that if the facts bear
out that there is a federal nexus then
the fbi will conduct an appropriate
investigation at that time but for now
we we continue in this
to support the texas rangers
how many more questions
to do just what they were supposed to do
hopefully they're not in league or their
magi officer was not in need when they
were familiarized with this training and
they should have done what they were
talking on facebook they were doing
drop the ball yeah i i don't have the
answer for that question
yeah welcome here welcome to texas and
uh this community has been hit
hard and i think it's it's noble that
the president's going to be here to
recognize that the pain and suffering
that this community is going through and
that's i think that's what leadership is
that's why that's why governor abbott's
here this while we take the leaders go
to where the problem is and right now
the problem is in uvalde texas
okay
okay it looks like they're gonna
not take any more questions here at this
press conference it appears um
this is a different
officer than what was giving uh answers
yesterday to the media's questions
apparently the guy yesterday because he
[ __ ] everything up because it clearly
if he watched the press conference
yesterday he did [ __ ] everything up yeah
um everyone in the chat here gabe is
saying that there was some other [ __ ] in
the beginning that was really wild
i want to see if we can find those if we
can find some clips of that um we are
going to do bonehead of the week you
guys know every single friday in the
second hour we do bone hint of the week
we are going to try to see if we can
find some clips of this uh yeah if
anyone's got the clips that you want us
to show uh dm it to tony or dm it to me
yeah yeah that would that would be
perfect if you guys can find those clips
um
or if you want to throw the link in the
chat then uh then i can yeah yeah yeah
that would be that would be perfect if
you've got those uh from the beginning
of this conference i just pulled the uh
now this um let's see if we can let's
see if i can go back and uh find oh
that's not what i want
see if i can go back and find the um
the part of this it takes a little bit
for the
for twitter to update the the feed
um and i don't know i think they're
going to turn off if they haven't turned
off the feed at now this live feed
that's the feed i was working off of
i did i just go i did go ahead and
retweet it if you guys want to re-watch
that press conference now this should be
able to they should leave that up on
their twitter
let's see if we can find
maybe aaron or something like that has
some clips here that um
of this press conference that they've
clipped out you know we rely on we rely
on such good reporters out there
and some people to uh take clips of live
coverage like this and really work it
into social media so that way they can
have it looks like cnn has something
here oh
let me get that link here
for all the listeners out there on the
directories you really should go watch
some of this press conference i know
you've been listening
to some of the stuff here um but it is
sometimes hard to tell the mood just
from the sound yeah um so it's um a good
idea to
go back and watch this stuff if you need
to again um if we ever try to find clips
we try to retweet them um as we find
them and as we show them we want to give
them credit but we also want to give you
guys a way to go back
that are listening to go back and see on
on at least on my timeline um you can
see all the stuff we talked about on the
show here is um here's a clip from cnn
i'm not sure exactly what this is but it
looks like from earlier
in the press conference let's take a
look see what it says
the fbi questions
uh can we have the one
this is this is the point where they
went to the fbi um for the investigation
that's not exactly what we want there um
so we'll continue to look here see if we
can find someone said there was some
wild [ __ ] in the beginning um that had
happened or that was spoken i don't know
it looks like gabe they were talking
about
um the uh
what had happened at the door at the
barricaded door because it that's really
the dispute here and it sounds like
to me
when they keep making up stories or they
keep changing their story about the
barricading and the timeline it really
does see that
seem like that's where they're trying to
hide some stuff now whatever that stuff
is i i don't know right like i have no
clue what they're trying to hide but
that's the problem here is that the
media is getting real pissed off well it
also appears to be that way well the
other thing i guess well
i'm gonna say it again like i honestly
believe that somebody's incompetence or
or lack of expertise in the situation
whether it was going to get their own
child inside the school
or whatever it was
i feel like somebody on their on their
task force on the on the one of the
police officers [ __ ] up and may have
accidentally shot someone
or made the situation worse by by going
in and right now i think they're trying
to cover up we've got the 12 minutes
between the car
stopping to entering the school we've
got the 15 minutes of radio chatter that
caitlin is talking about that has gone
just
poof into thin air and then we've also
got the question of like okay we had 90
minutes before we actually stopped the
shooter but before that we had officers
who went in and actually only rescued
their children first
so there's a lot of questions the whole
thing is sus like it stinks to [ __ ]
the end of time you know you know what's
you know what just absolutely bonkers
batshit crazy about this whole narrative
and this whole thing about these press
conferences uh betto uh interrupting the
nra presser that the governor gave um
right on right down to the ten minutes
that it took that he had to get into
that school in the 15 minutes of chatter
that's missing or whatever it is yeah
all this all this could have been
stopped by one [ __ ] one
[ __ ] greg abbott could have
[ __ ] made sure that he said no i'm
not gonna let i'm not gonna let anyone
just get a [ __ ] gun we're not gonna
encourage people to just have [ __ ]
assault weapons that can [ __ ] tear
apart children
it doesn't make any sense we
we are so [ __ ]
convinced that backdoors and armed
guards and all this [ __ ] is the answer
the answer is
not to have the ability to tear apart
little children and teachers and
parishioners at churches and [ __ ]
patrons at grocery stores with a goddamn
weapon of war it is really [ __ ]
simple
we've done it before in this country we
have done it before this is absolutely
batshit crazy
that this these peop these [ __ ] law
enforcement officers who were terrified
of the of the the just
the thought that their limbs would be
ripped off by this guy's weapon
that they wouldn't go in and help save
these little children and these teachers
they were scared
they were scared of the firearm
they even said it it's the gun it's the
[ __ ] gun we're scared of getting shot
they weren't saying oh we're scared of
the maniac yeah
he's a lunatic we're scared of him they
were scared of being shot folks it's the
[ __ ] gun it's always been the gun
there are no good guys there are no bad
guys there's no back door there's no
[ __ ] great tactics there's none of
that none of that i told you the other
day i don't have a crystal ball
but i know this i have kids that go to a
[ __ ] elementary school they lock the
back door because they're terrified of
being murdered
and a teacher just happened to step
outside to get their [ __ ] cell phone
and propped open that door
which gave him the opportunity to go in
that school
but it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
that they propped open the door and
there was 10 minutes and 15 minutes of
chatter and how long it took him what
matters is greg abbott allowed this to
[ __ ] happen in his state he knew this
would happen
they knew it
they don't give a [ __ ] and it's time for
texans to say enough is enough i don't
give a [ __ ] about back doors i don't
care about what your [ __ ] active
shooter drills and your tactics are
we're gonna make sure that weapons of
war can't get into the [ __ ] school
and it's not about entrances and [ __ ]
locking doors it's about not having the
[ __ ]
you do not need the second amendment
does not afford you the right to rip
apart children in a school it does not
or the ability get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] and if you can't protect
your dumb ass [ __ ] walmart bought tv
with a with with a [ __ ] shotgun then
you don't need and you can't kill a
[ __ ]
a wild animal like a deer or turkey
or an elk with a goddamn hunting rifle
then you do your you don't need a
[ __ ] gun in the first place
you don't need one
stop with your [ __ ] [ __ ]
stop with your terror stop with your
domestic terrorism
it's enough is enough is enough of this
[ __ ]
it's time this country pluck its head
out of its [ __ ] ass
we do not need
to be lectured at a [ __ ] podium from
any law enforcement officer about what
their [ __ ] tactics are for an active
shooter right
we do not
the fact that we have the protocols we
have i mean some of these i think there
was a document a protocol that that
actually leaked yesterday as to how
you're supposed to
handle an active shooter the fact that
we live in a society where that's just
yeah we gotta we gotta we gotta really
plan for this guys like not like a oh
this happens like once in a blue moon
this is something that happens so
regularly that we have a whole team that
has put together a document on a
step-by-step process of how you're
supposed to enter exit retrieve how
you're supposed to uh handle victims
like
the fact that we live in a society where
this is now just the commonplace this is
the normal thing this is
the the everyday occurrence
is so gross we have to give gabe we have
to give paramedics battlefield training
right battlefield type training on on on
on weapons of war ripping apart body
parts
we have to give our paramedics
war type training
it's [ __ ] gross it's disgusting it's
un-american it's unpatriotic that you
would cheer
for the type of weapons that would rip
apart your [ __ ] children your
grandchildren your community members
your friends your colleagues your
[ __ ]
your fellow church members what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you people
i found the clip here gabe um i don't
this this appears to be part of the news
um this is on uh abc news clip it's
about a minute 37 let's listen to this
see what he has to say here i think this
is the part that everyone was talking
about
we know from video evidence 1127
the exterior door
suspected
of what the
where we knew the the shooter entered
ramos
was propped open by a teacher
oh my god he is not he's not he's not
going to do what i think he's going to
do is he he's going to do exactly what
he did before he's blaming the teacher
god you stupid sons of [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] god you pieces of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
11 28
the suspect vehicle crashes into the
ditch as previously described
it did not crash into the ditch game
i've seen this [ __ ] picture of this
truck it is [ __ ] sitting in the ditch
mm-hmm it didn't roll over he he drove
into the ditch to park the car to hide
the [ __ ] he said he was gonna go
to the school to murder these children
he knew the school he went to the
goddamn school when he was in elementary
school
this is just complete [ __ ] nonsense
he's still lying about [ __ ]
the teacher runs the room 132 to
retrieve a phone and that same team
teacher walks back to the exit door
and door remains propped open
there are two males as reported by
regional director escalante yesterday
there were two males at a funeral home
that when he heard the crash they went
to the crash scene
when they arrived at the crash scene
before they got there they saw a man
with a gun exit the passenger side with
a backpack and they immediately began
running
ramos began shooting at him did not hit
him
one of the males
fell when he was running
both males return to the funeral home
while they're running
and then again
we see through video
teacher re-emerges inside the school and
panic and apparently calls 9-1-1
9-1-1 call at 11 30. there was a crash
man with a gun
11 31
the suspect reaches last row of vehicles
in the school parking lot
1131 the suspect shooting began
at the school while patrol vehicles
got to the funeral home
uh
i
gabe
i'm i'm going to tell you
that tonight at this stupid [ __ ]
gunless nra
blood on their hands rally
that they're gonna have
ted cruz
is gonna get up in front of in front of
that microphone
and he's going to blame that teacher for
that back door being open oh
easily
because of that a [ __ ] cowardly
pathetic piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
wouldn't i wouldn't put it past their
orange mussolini jesus to say something
about it either
oh yeah of course i mean why would you
why would you expect anything less
these guys are looking for anything and
anyone to blame
besides the gun oh my god you pieces of
[ __ ] [ __ ] you pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
i said the other day back doors are
[ __ ] locked they on my daughter's
school they don't even have handles on
those [ __ ]
they don't even have handles on them but
they're doors the children enter and
exit through those doors
this backdoor [ __ ] like it's some kind
of curious [ __ ] thing
there's there's all kinds of doors on
school side doors back doors front
entrances main entrances non-main
entrance west entrance east entrance
these schools were not built
in parts of our country with the thought
of well what if a [ __ ] what if a
[ __ ] mass murderer comes in here and
tries to kill these children
they were not built that way
they were not
that we didn't have that idea because it
has not been that long ago that this
country
didn't have this inside of our [ __ ]
culture
you know what else tony
you know what else uh when it was
originally created
didn't have the intent that it has today
the second amendment
when our founding fathers you know wrote
up the second amendment they did not
anticipate a [ __ ] could show up
with an assault rifle
and lay out multiple rounds per minute
slaughtering children
if people really want to say oh you know
what second amendment you know what go
grab a [ __ ] musket put in the gun
powder put in the pellets and you shoot
it
whenever i hear the argument of people
who are like well you know second
amendment the founding fathers intended
this no they didn't
no they did not
they could barely anticipate what was
going to happen
the next day right
whether it was
war or or domestic international threat
health whatever it was
they barely had their [ __ ] together when
they wrote that document
you're going to tell me that they
expected that people were going to have
the ability to own an assault rifle
that that's what they intended
get the [ __ ] out of here
vile pieces of [ __ ] vile pieces of [ __ ]
i want to show you a video here gabe um
um of lauren bobert and but i think
she's on our she's on our bonehead
though list isn't she somewhere she made
it she made a listen
well we'll we'll wait wait wait for the
okay okay all right we'll wait for
bonehead of the week um all right i know
i don't want anyone to get uh too out of
sorts here and and hopefully we will
find more out about this press
conference um as it goes on and and what
i mean about that is let these
journalists figure out and these
reporters figure out what is fact that
they're saying into the microphone and
what is not because it seems that the
timeline has changed again and if it
will change again and again and again so
um i do want to make sure that we don't
leave this um with just pure blooded
anger here um
we had brent there hewn on he's a friend
of yours
and um and brent was fun to talk to um
you guys know he does the satire and
comedy on twitter and on social media
and he did a fabulous
i mean absolutely
brilliant take on ted cruz and really
honestly
um
this whole
we can't have gun control [ __ ] um and he
used the the satire of the doors and ted
cruz i want to show everyone um there's
there's actually parts of this that are
you you cannot help but laugh
and realize that that as as we
as we go through this as a country and
as we deal with this as a country
we have to make sure
that we laugh still we have to make sure
that we still are able to laugh that is
the only way that we recognize ourselves
as humans because let me tell you
something these republicans out there
they're not laughing they're not
they're not laughing is probably the
issue and one reason why is because
they're not funny but brent did a great
take it's it's actually
even though it is hilarious it has the
underlying tones of what actually needs
to happen in this country listen do you
want to talk about how we could have
prevented the horror that played out
across the street look the killer
entered here the same way the killer
entered in santa fe
through a back door you know i'm
absolutely sick and tired of this [ __ ]
you know that
this country's got a problem and it
seems like nobody wants to talk about it
well i guess i'm the one with the balls
to talk about it then
because we got a door problem in this
country
and to those of you saying oh this is
not the time to be talking about doors
why do you got gotta politicize doors
well we can't even string two or three
days together in this country where a
door doesn't hurt somebody we need
common sense door reform and we need it
now
you can't hurt people in a place
if there are no doors to get in that
place get rid of all of them that's what
i say
restaurants malls movie theaters schools
stores sporting events concerts work
home school
churches
and you know what they say when god
closes the door he opens the window so
we might as well get rid of them too
car doors automatic doors
semi-automatic doors revolving doors
what do you need all that
door for
revolving door our forefathers couldn't
even fathom a door like that when they
wrote the constitution
knock knock jokes they gotta go three's
company theme song it's gotta go yes
even doors on the radio sorry jim
morrison but you gotta go too
and all those politicians that are in
the
the pocket of all these door companies
shame on you
shame on you
if it weren't for
people like you we could end all this
and we could be safe
short of a goddamn kool-aid man bursting
through the wall but you people don't
care about kool-aid do you no
you're too busy drinking it
bren
brent brent brent brent brent thank you
thank you for um putting putting our
rage in our anger into a structure that
makes us laugh and makes us it makes us
think about with satire um brent is an
absolute absolute
brilliant genius when it comes to satire
um and thank you what's funny is
together so for you know for anyone who
doesn't know uh
brent and i we share the same acting
teacher and so we were just in an
audition class together so it's
interesting to get a completely
different side of him right everyone
sees this character right you can see
his stand up too
but like in class he's you know he is
different right right well when we
interviewed him which we interviewed him
he's completely different and he talks
about a lot of these issues and he talks
about like rural america like and where
a lot of this [ __ ] gun nut crazy [ __ ]
comes from i grew up i grew up in this
part of the country where they they feel
like they have to be obsessed with guns
and it's part of their identity look
guns can be part of your identity you
can still own guns there's no one
very few [ __ ] people who are even
close to being elected
are saying no guns whatsoever like we
are not even close to in this country
being in a place where we could do what
scotland and australia did and basically
melt down all the [ __ ] firearms
well they said the opportunity yesterday
the day before and they decided to stall
it and stop right
and a lot of this needs to be backbone
um but it's up to you to have backbone
it's you that has backbone out there in
in this nonsense where people say that
well it doesn't count it doesn't matter
well if you feel that way and you
continue to project that image and that
and that into the universe that is
exactly what's going to happen um
i believe
that there is a person running for
governor uh in the state of texas that
can be a national leader and to show the
country what it takes and the courage
that it takes to come to
grips with what is the problem and how
to fix it
and you we're we're not going to get rid
we're not going to get rid of total gun
violence in this country because we have
the second amendment we know that you're
not going to be able to get rid of all
gun violence in this country because of
the second amendment but
jesus [ __ ] christ can we stop the
slaughter
of children stop the slaughter of people
in a church stop the slaughter of people
in a [ __ ] grocery store can we please
please just do the things that we know
will work to stop those incidents and
stop the killing it's enough of this
[ __ ]
i mean the other thing that i hear
people say especially marco rubio the
other day he talked about you know even
if we got rid of the guns
murderous people would still find a way
to act out and kill people okay all
right fine let's just work through that
thought experiment for a second you
remove all the guns what are people left
with okay i got a [ __ ] bow and arrow
i got a knife i got a hatchet or an axe
or something like that
but when you compare the end result and
impact of a semi-automatic gun
versus a [ __ ] hatchet
how many are you gonna have to go
through to actually kill the same amount
of people
that a gun would uh hold on guys hold on
like no that's at most you're gonna hit
someone the [ __ ] head with the wood
part of the axe right but like you will
not be able to
to actually
create the same amount of collateral
damage in death
you know in comparison to using a gun
well but these idiots try to use that as
an example like a murderous person is
going to continue to murder people well
but if a murderous person doesn't have a
gun
then but what's going on here they're
they're they're absolutely
hellbent on banning a medical procedure
to save the children to save lives and
you're gonna see this lauren bober clip
where she claims that millions of people
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
nonsense and made up [ __ ] statistic
just because you read it on the internet
lauren bobert
but they're going to save lives they'll
do anything any absolutely anything
they'll even they'll even make
uh
life begin before the boner
if that's what it takes to save one just
one just make sure there's gonna be
abortion
no matter how much you ban it
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you we have
we have [ __ ] laws that that are to
prevent people from murdering other
[ __ ] and we still have murder
we have speed limit laws we have traffic
laws we have fraud laws we have all
kinds of laws on the books
and people break them
they're going to break them
the point is not
is not that the law is going to stop
someone from murdering someone with a
gun or otherwise
it's to try to prevent this stuff from
happening we can do something about the
weapons of war in our country we can do
something about it it is it's almost
like uh it's almost like covet right
oh my gosh there was something that
could have reduced
the amount of deaths in spread of covid
if we just wore a mask or we got the
vaccine
you're telling me that if we had done
something as small as kept a distance
wore a mask
stayed at home
that we could have prevented
potentially
more deaths than we have
but republicans want to say no we can't
you know listen we got to do anything
anything but i'm not willing to wear a
mask i'm not willing to get a vaccine
i'm not willing to do anything that
would help the betterment of humanity
but i'll do anything
except those things that will actually
prevent it right right well i mean why
why would you expect them to do that
right why would you expect him to do
that
listeners uh we have a lot of new
listeners out there if you are a new
listener we have reached the point in
the friday show we are a little little
behind on this but we did have the press
conference there um we in the second
hour of every friday we go through the
bonehead of the week poll which you vote
and we break down you get to decide the
bonehead of the week we break it down
for you
so right after this break we will come
back and break down bonehead of the week
stay right here do not leave bone end of
the week right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back
on the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
dears tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light hope it don't
rain tomorrow so we can circle the city
again
yours
bomb
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we are in the second hour
of the tony michaels podcast we
broadcast live every single monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter and
twitch and simulcast from the midas
touch facebook page but we have reached
the point of the friday show for
bonehead of the week
look at that transition i'm getting
better and better at this
way better and better at this
boy did we have a lot of [ __ ]
boneheads this week uh we just watched
some of the boneheads that we have um
they didn't make the list but we got we
had some of the boneheads on um this
press conference here
boy oh boy oh boy
if i could put more people on the list i
would if i could put all of the texas
lawmakers that are actually in office
and don't have any sort of empathy or
care for human life or just want to [ __ ]
a gun
they would be on the list you mean they
got gun boners is that what you're dude
they got guns in the front and guns in
the back door
the back door
speaking of back door a guy who who is
obsessed with back doors now he's
obsessed with back door reform
senator ted cruz he made our list texas
attorney general ken paxton that pile of
[ __ ] he made our list and then the
biggest of them all uh governor greg
abbott the one who caused this tragedy
in uvalde that's right i said it
governor abbott caused this he caused it
if you don't believe that you are
[ __ ] deluded you are kidding yourself
if you don't think that these lawmakers
made sure to pass laws to where this was
easier to happen they have caused this
they have blood on their hands and not
only that not only that two of these
[ __ ] that are on this list are
still gonna go to the nra and stand up
and cheer
um as they [ __ ] piss on the
pile of dead bodies right
the 19 dead children and the two
teachers in uvalde texas they're going
to cheer yeah take this you can take
this from my cold dead hands
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] and so is the
former guy but these were our
contestants this week we felt like that
this was probably
the short list here of people who not
only could prevent this um [ __ ] from
happening but continued to
say stupid [ __ ] about back doors and
stuff and of course we've seen just seen
the clip of the uh
law enforcement's press conference it
looks like they're gonna blame that it
looks like they're gonna blame the
teachers get it was those teachers fault
i mean let's just run through the list
we're blaming video games right blaming
mental health but we won't do anything
about it okay so you [ __ ] you if you
have mental health right uh we are
blaming um [ __ ] back doors right
we're blaming wait what culture woke
yeah the [ __ ] wokers oh yeah right
workers and those [ __ ] teachers
yeah you know at some point i bet you
republicans will say
it's the parents fault no no it's the
students
man if you're not fast enough to dodge
these bullets then you're just prior to
probably probably part of the cancer
culture and you know what you're just
trying to cancel that guy's right to go
in and slaughter children for crying out
loud it's part of cancer culture i mean
like they say right if you can dodge a
wrench you can dodge a bullet that might
be that might be the case
these pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] here they
aren't here's our um
our contestants this week the boneheads
of the week they all kind of [ __ ]
themselves right i don't even know
really where to start here um of course
we know that um ken paxton he got short
on the list which is kind of surprising
this guy didn't get hardly any of the
votes well you know i guess
when you're suggesting ideas giving
teachers guns is maybe the least
ridiculous thing in terms of comparing
it against back doors
and other things to blame right well let
me see if i i just have to assume let me
see if i can find the clip that you're
talking about where ken paxton because
he was on fox news i believe where he
said this stupid [ __ ] where he's gonna
and i'm also i just want to pray i'm
going to preview
the first uh maybe a couple minutes
of the what was that because it happens
to feature all three of these people
okay but i do it until ted cruz i'm
still editing but i at least wanted to
give people a taste because i've been
talking about it this week and i'll get
it out by the end of the day
um but you know here we go i got one
better for you here he is on newsmax oh
yeah a different trader tv network yeah
the news mecca you know yeah
newsmax get that [ __ ] out of here
of course ken paxton down here in the
ken paxton shirt
guys vote for me somehow i won my
primary even though i'm under federal
investigation and have been for some
time because i'm a [ __ ] criminal um
well let's see
at this point if you see on the screen
here it says 14 children one dead
teacher so this that like they haven't
even mopped up the bodies yeah this is
they haven't really got all the limbs
that are this is
as at this point we believe this is the
number turns out we're wrong right right
and here's what here's what the the
great attorney general that [ __ ] [ __ ]
box had to say
about the shooting let's listen as as
you well know the state of texas not a
stranger to shootings that either begin
in schools or wander into schools what
in the [ __ ]
not a stranger oh well yeah this is
familiar this is familiar mr attorney
general who is the top law enforcement
officer in the goddamn state
we love it here in texas when people go
into schools and shoot and murder
children
how do you lead into someone to be like
hey we're going to take
my transition the transition on this is
like listen we're going to get your take
and obviously someone who has experience
with school shootings and mass shootings
in your state that should never be the
first thing you say to introduce someone
onto your show
but unfortunately they use it and they
say
this is a good thing because you have
experience
these [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
let's listen
uh
i know your team has dealt with this
before what were some of the solutions
and i know that governor abbott and
lieutenant governor patrick have also
come up with tasks for task forces to
harden these schools so they're not easy
targets easy prey for crazy people who
go nuts with firearms
okay this whole hardened school thing
this is really [ __ ] dumb
this is really [ __ ] dumb like these
these these schools aren't even scared
of like tornadoes anymore in some of
these places they're more terrified and
do more drills
of a [ __ ] weapon coming into school
and murdering children and and teachers
than they do a tornado ripping through
their community and he's like yeah what
you put together tax forces to make sure
that this happens continually is that
what he's that's what i hear him saying
yeah i mean what they're saying is and
he says it in another segment which i
feature in the video but uh that i'll
wrap up but
uh
in this interview and the other one they
talk about obviously how they can
prevent it right but the reason they
need to armed arms is because they don't
have the resources
to stop it it's i don't know man it's
almost like
if you remove the guns from the equation
you wouldn't need to have more people in
law enforcement to stop said shootings
or spend money on i don't know
hardening the schools maybe give them
[ __ ] pencils and erasers you [ __ ]
dummies
stop taking away their [ __ ] math
books what a bunch of [ __ ]
uh
what what can you tell us has been
talked about in the past what has been
implemented and what hasn't been
yeah sadly this has happened again and
it's a horrible tragedy but the types of
things that we talked about and i'll
never forget it after the santa fe
shooting it was having one point of
entry making it more difficult more
people even
make sure that they
and having potentially
teachers and other administrators who
have gone through training who are armed
because first responders typically can't
get there in time to prevent a shooting
or when they do get there they're scared
of being shot as if a teacher so so what
gabe i'm i'm wondering i guess we're
just going to
all the teachers are gonna have to walk
around and [ __ ] body armor yeah and
they have a semi-automatic rifle slung
over their back just in case this [ __ ]
happens because it sounds like texas
wants to make sure they harden their
schools where they have armed guards not
just at the door inside the classrooms
and really honestly to make sure to
protect those
those uh students from those woke ass
teachers now that they're gonna arm them
now that they're gonna arm the woke ass
teachers you probably are gonna have to
make sure the students are wearing flak
jackets and they have their own
semi-automatic rifles yeah protect
themselves from the crazy ass mother
wokers that are the teachers trying to
teach them crt and [ __ ] this this this
nonsense and this delusion and this
[ __ ] just absolute vile dribble
does not stop and it's not going to
folks people like ken paxton shouldn't
even [ __ ] have his own t-shirt that
has his name on it okay
let alone being the texas attorney
general running for it and then getting
the nomination
listen if you if you are in texas and
you are hearing my voice right now go
fire these [ __ ] that is your
choice in texas that's your choice and
in any state really that is nonsense
like here in missouri we have the same
stupid-ass [ __ ] that goes on at our
state capitol and continues to go on
about this gun [ __ ] and they continue to
scourge i'm sick of this [ __ ] i'm gonna
get him i i'm i'm done with him
[ __ ] ken paxton [ __ ] him all the way off
all the way the [ __ ] off [ __ ] this guy
with the doors and the [ __ ] giving
teachers guns and making sure they're
the targets you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
speaking of piece of [ __ ] let's move to
our next piece of [ __ ] garbage here
senator ted cruz
oh my god we don't have to very go very
far for this [ __ ] do we no you
just gotta go through the back door same
[ __ ] [ __ ] with the back door we just
watched the [ __ ] [ __ ] with uh the the
the video
that uh that brent did about the back
door [ __ ]
this one slimy piece of [ __ ] now i'm
telling you this backdoor stuff we can
continue on this backdoor stuff but this
[ __ ] is gonna go he's gonna go
to the nra blood on their hands gunless
gathering tonight and he's gonna blame
that [ __ ] teacher for propping open
that back door he's gonna [ __ ] do it
because he's a [ __ ] coward he's a
goddamn coward he won't [ __ ] press
the blame where the blame needs to be
pressed and it's it's in his own goddamn
pocket
that [ __ ] money that he's taken from
the nra that piece of [ __ ] trash
sorry i'm a little no it's fine no it's
not i mean there is stuff they're all
they're all pieces of [ __ ] uh if you're
gonna play that clip whenever you're
gonna play it i got the other video too
that features the back door yeah well i
i'm i'm i'm not gonna play any more
backdoor clips i will play this this is
a video i did this video last year last
year i did this video and i was like oh
this sounds pretty evergreen but i'm i'm
sure this is going to last for a long
time as long as ted cruz has any
microphone to speak into
let's listen to me from a year ago have
you ever noticed that republicans seem
to be in a competition of which one of
them can be more [ __ ] repugnant than
ted cruz
[ __ ] them i'm just i'm just saying it
does seem like a [ __ ] competition
with these guys trying to figure out who
can be more [ __ ] repugnant than ted
cruz ron johnson goes on a tirade this
morning about faith and morals and
wokers and all kinds of [ __ ] i mean
he's really seems to be trying to out
ted cruz ted cruz it's [ __ ] gross
speaking of ted cruz you got a little
sample of what um
of what uh you wanted to play here let's
see we did dude there we go maybe
maybe maybe not i don't know what the
hell is going on here
and the
18 young children and two adults were
killed
i don't know what's going on i also
loaded in the other one so go to the
oh did you okay yeah
well yeah well maybe here we go okay are
we getting it maybe here i can see it
tuesday may 24th 19th yeah it's not it's
not much it's not doing what you want no
this guy this whacking go to the other
one go to the other one did you load it
in yeah yeah here it is okay here we go
on tuesday may 24th 19 young children
and two adults were killed in a school
shooting in uvalde texas it took over 90
minutes to stop the shooter but it has
now been revealed that some police
officers breached the school to get
their own children out before
the shooter was taken down
[Music]
texas law enforcement officials have
changed their stories so many times i
wouldn't be surprised if we find out
they personally escorted the gunman into
the school this was the deadliest
american school shooting since the 2012
massacre at sandy hook elementary this
is the 27th school shooting this year we
have had 213 mass shootings in less than
six months of 2022. you don't need to be
enrolled in ron desantis school of
banned mathematics to know how bad these
numbers are the uvalde shooting happened
just 10 days after the horrific shooting
at the buffalo supermarket on may 14th
we unfortunately live in a country where
guns outnumber people and gun violence
has become an everyday occurrence the
correlation between the number of guns
in america and the number of gun-related
deaths in america is undeniable maybe
this slaughtering of innocent children
is a wake-up call for republicans they
are the pro-life party after all and
they've said on multiple occasions they
want to save the children
so you know what i'm sure they have a
plan to fix this epidemic and prevent
future mass shootings i'm sure by now
texas senator ted cruz has offered a
solution one of the things that that
everyone agreed is don't have all of
these unlocked back doors have one door
into and out of the school i'm sorry
what was that
what what was that what was that oh man
thanks for the preview especially with
this with the with these boneheads
now yeah i gotta move along here we are
we are getting to the bottom of the hour
here
um
i guess i guess maybe we'll go to the
who's the who's the alpha cuck is that
the alpha cuck that we got this that's
alpha alpha clock alpha what was in the
alpha cuck last week
he might have been i know he might have
been no i can't this guy this guy always
appears on our radar no actually i don't
think he was last week uh i think with
someone else but he was he was maybe the
week before that
um
but what is this
this week what happened
you've done your research on this
because we talked about this the other
day yeah nick this week nick fuentes has
uh has become the alpha cuck for his
projection
and his hate
against himself
um
nick fuentes is someone who is a nazi
uh just gonna put it out there yeah and
it's it's not us we're not i mean he's
he's a proud nazi yeah yeah he
doesn't like anyone else that isn't
white that isn't straight
anyway what ends up happening is he
reveals a screenshot to prove some dumb
point that he has
turns out that in said screenshot
he shows the tabs
of the the websites that he's on because
he's trying to show his he's trying to
show his google numbers down here at the
bottom right right
yeah so in this
he's like all right cool got a
screenshot instead of taking a
screenshot of the actual pa or i think
this might have been a video or
something and there's a screenshot that
was taken from it but what we see here
is there's a bit of a
graphic image in the background there
right if we enhance
and look at what that photo is let's let
you know let me let me see if i can pull
that one up and see what that uh
there it is um i don't know i don't know
if youtube allows us to put this up but
i don't give a [ __ ] and there we go yeah
so
look so there's a pho there's a there's
a video that he has loaded in his safari
tabs in the background there
and
it matches up with a
video
a sex video with
with a trans person and
which i mean hey whatever suits your
fancy yeah
again
watch whatever porn you want as long as
it's as long as it's legal porn you know
it's like right right yeah yeah i'm
completely fine with whatever porn you
want to watch as long as i mean you are
who you are and you're free to who you
are and
you know if you don't feel
uh comfortable in your own skin yeah i
i'm even i'm even for people uh watching
porn that maybe they don't
um project that type of
um
feelings out in the open i'm i'm okay
with people being closeted by the way i
have no
i have no ill feeling to someone who
wants to remain that's your choice you
have the freedom in this country to have
the sexuality that you want to to
identify as you want that's your [ __ ]
freedom that's their constitutional
right as far as i'm concerned you got
the constitutional right to watch
whatever porn you want but this idea
that this [ __ ] basically calls
for the the genocide
of a certain type of people
and he may be that person it is it and
it's it's not just vile it's projection
and it continues to show you right it
continues to show you that this this
fascist ideology they really are they
really are frightened by their own
[ __ ] being by their own identity it's
[ __ ] weird i mean every attack and
accusation they have is just another
confession
well and you you can almost see it and
watch for it right like this this
[ __ ] where these cops down there in
uvalde are are
light-handedly blaming the teacher for
propping open the back door as if as if
that teacher her intent or his intent
whoever it was to prop open that back
door so that those kids would be
murdered you
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
i mean how long until we start banning
teachers tony all right well you know
they're trying they're just saying
certainly
they went for the books
next they're coming for the teachers
because the teachers
are who actually let
them a shooter isn't you know they they
let the shooter in and then they're the
cause for the mass shooting not the gun
not the the laws that allow this person
to easily buy a gun
but the teachers the teachers the
teachers who went out and got the got
the phone from their car propped the
door open
i'm telling you man i told you the other
day that they locked those [ __ ] back
doors i told you they lock them and nope
nope no they don't lock them the back
doors we need to ban back doors and all
this [ __ ] right
morons nick fuentes thank you for being
the alpha duck of the week you never let
us down i'm sure you'll make the list
somewhere next week oh yeah after
absolutely no way he's not going to make
the list oh no no
look he's been in the running before for
other parts he's been a
dishonorable mention he's been alphacut
he's run the
whole spectrum of stuff and [ __ ]
dirty violence and he will continue to
i'm sure absolutely well
i don't know what is it what his excuses
about um his self-hatred but um i'm sure
he does have one i want to show you we
we have the dishonorable mention
uh you made lauren bobert the dishonor
was it after i sent you this video this
morning yeah yeah i was looking for
someone to put in there i think i'm
getting the video pj sent me this from
patriot takes yeah and um
i'm not gonna say the word that mj used
but um we decided not to make her alpha
cuck maybe another word another c word
in there but um we decided you decided
to uh give her the the the great honor
of dishonorable mention yeah for this
video um in this video it appears she's
driving in the car and making a video
which
um is not is that seems illegal well it
seems
headed at a bare minimum
but you know you know she is a [ __ ]
bonehead that's why she's on the list
and she remains on the permanent list of
boneheads in my oh yeah
also she says some really dumb [ __ ] in
this video which is not surprising
either because it is lauren bobert the
bobo the clown
oh let's see if we can bear through this
couple minutes here we go
boba the count just bobo the clown
lauren bobert the dishonorable mention
bonehead of the week
so i am on my way to carbondale colorado
um there's supposedly
an organized march the march for our
lives that's going to take place and i'm
really interested to see
if people know what they're marching for
she's such a [ __ ] idiot okay so so
she is she's making the um she's making
the
she's making the [ __ ]
uh assumption here that people who are
going to march for the slaughtered
people like actual slaughter bodies the
stacks of [ __ ] children you know
these people are like save the children
save the children there's a [ __ ]
stack of dead children's bodies all over
this country and she's like i don't even
know what they've known what they're
marching for you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'll say it i mean i don't you use
that word a lot but when you're talking
about marjorie tate or green lauren
brobert and folks like marsha blackburn
you just it it's a perfect [ __ ]
description
it really for someone to live in
colorado right you've got columbine
you've got aurora right right two
different events where somebody came in
and used a gun to murder people
and then you've got this person
lauren bobert who says
i'm showing up
for the march for our lives march
i wonder if they know what they're
really marching for
the [ __ ] lives
the lives it's a march for our lives
it's
[ __ ]
straightforward
it is the name it says what it is it's
for our lives
living
and those who were murdered
and she has the audacity to go i wonder
if they know what they're really
marching for all right
shut the [ __ ] up well i i can't shut her
up i gotta play the rest of it gabe i'm
really i apologize but let's let's hear
what else this [ __ ] bonehead has to
say
um i guess this is
supposed to be
the beginning of people speaking out to
to take away
our second amendment rights
and i'm not i would love to stop it here
and have more commentary but i don't
know if i have enough time to [ __ ]
lay into this tweed happy about him
um
if this is really a march for our lives
let's march against abortion
because i was looking at statistics and
there are nearly 1
million
abortions per year in america
that is a bunch of [ __ ] that's not
even that's not even a real thing she
literally she literally just went on the
website that she wanted that number of
of went on reddit and like yeah that's
the truth it's a million
you know what's up she's like you know
what's bigger than a million a bajillion
bajillion abortions in america every
year you know what you know what lauren
bobert if you can hear me
i think i think we should have at least
at least four million abortions in a
year that's what i'm saying yeah
absolutely let's do that you [ __ ]
idiot you are such a [ __ ] bonehead
like
there's there gabe did you know there's
650 million people who die from gun
violence in the united states every
single year 650 million
somehow 650 million it's like it's like
that's like double the population here
but yeah
331 million people in this country which
by the way we own 393 million guns in
this right that's an action that's an
actual that's an actual number
when the guns outnumber the people you
know you have a problem
this [ __ ] idiot just absolutely pulls
how
many did she add
from the original number to get to a
million was it three zeros i don't know
four zeros i have no idea the the
craziest part about this whole thing
it's like
some procedures
um that are
are called abortion procedures right
aren't even
really abortions like there's no life
it's just literally a clump of cells
right
like it literally is a clump of cells
like sometimes an eptopic pregnancy
where they actually take out the the
cells to save a woman's life because
she's it's gonna rupture and she's
possibly gonna die i had a friend of
mine who would not be alive today if
republicans had their way and
you know it saddens me that you have to
[ __ ] explain actual [ __ ] real [ __ ]
to boneheads like this and they still
don't get it because they're like well
there's a million a million get the [ __ ]
out of here now listen to what she says
after this this is oh this is classic
bobo the clown here
one million do you know how many gun
violent deaths there are gun related
deaths there are in america per year
fifteen thousand
hmm
a drop in the bucket i'd say yeah like
19 kids and you yuvaldi that's just a
drop in the bucket just a drop in the
bucket who gives a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
just a drop in the butt you are a vile
disgusting pathetic cowardly piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] lauren bobert
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] garbage
claiming to save the children and all
this [ __ ] and then you're like ah those
children and yuvaldi that are stacked up
that they're bot they're they [ __ ]
have to identify them with dna because
their bodies are ripped apart by [ __ ]
guns that you claim you love and you
have your children posed in front of a
christmas tree you piece of [ __ ]
trash you piece of
[ __ ] trash
i i don't even know if there's another
word to describe her i used the c word
earlier and i'm not going to continue
this nonsense here but you get you get
the idea how stupid she [ __ ] is
oh just a drop in the butt are you
kidding me
my response to this i tweeted it i said
the dumber the better like literally in
this and right right now the dumber the
[ __ ] idea they can just spew into a
[ __ ] camera the [ __ ] better it is
i feel like a drop in the bucket holy
[ __ ] i have lost
at least 10
to 15 iq points watching the video of
lauren bober try to come up with some
random number about abortions and come
up with a number about gun deaths right
and then be like
[ __ ] who cares
who cares about those people in buffalo
or the people in the church in
california there's that's just a drop
who cares it's just a drop in a bike
don't worry about your children being
killed in schools it's just a drop in
the bucket it's just hey look look it's
for the it's for the it's
look it's
it's for it's for the good okay for the
good of humanity okay your kids died so
we could live
that's what she's trying to argue here
right this is the party that wants to
give rights to unborn
women
not unborn men just unborn women
because unborn lives matter right those
lives matter not the actual living
children and the living babies [ __ ]
those kids you know
lauren bobert uh using her words
obviously
um
but you you look at this and
this party
wants to excuse the deaths and justify
them to say well in comparison to uh
abortions it's not really a big deal you
know it's like one here 20 there
whatever you know it's like
could you be worse of a person
honestly could could lauren bobert be
any worse and i and i asked that
question and i know the answer is yes
she could because she will be
she will be
and she will prove it to us at some
point in the near future she will do
something to say oh the bar wasn't low
enough
let me just [ __ ] knock it off the
rack and put it on the ground
oh
she's just straight up a [ __ ]
absolute
bonehead absolute bonehead speaking
speaking of [ __ ] boneheads
let's go to the bonehead of the week
here
uh greg abbott the the the disgraced
pathetic governor
of texas who has blood on his hands who
is the reason why
the shooting and you've already killed
19 children and two teachers
um
why we have the traumatic images of
parents trying to barricade past the
armed guards at the school trying to
prevent them from going in to save their
children because they wouldn't because
they're scared of bullets apparently
um
i mean also it's just also completely
understandable that somebody would be
afraid of bullets
you as a human i know that a bullet will
kill you
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna probably
hesitate before i say well you know and
these are people that are trained law
enforcement professionals right whether
they're trained well enough or not these
people are the ones who are supposed to
be out there defending us they're the
ones who actually have the ability to
wear protective armor and actually have
weapons to go against someone else who
has a weapon and even they
even they don't want to go in
and when they do
it's only to get their own kids because
[ __ ] your kids right my kids matter gabe
the reason why is because these weapons
are designed
to neutralize someone even in body armor
these are weapons of war
like the gun manufacturers are
manufacturing these weapons these
assaults assault style weapons to make
sure
that if someone has body armor on that
they can stop them that's the whole
[ __ ] point that's why it rips through
your flesh that's why it tears off your
arms and it makes your head explode if
it hits impact and i'm gonna be graphic
here i want to be graphic i want you to
realize and i i wish
i wish the media
would would would stop showing pictures
of the children that were [ __ ]
that were slaughtered of them smiling
and being great children and i wish they
would show pictures of their dead
[ __ ] bodies
maybe that would [ __ ] change people's
minds in this country not to show the
pictures where they're standing when in
school awards that's dead that's dead
and long gone greg abbott made sure our
bonehead of the week made sure that
didn't happen anymore to that child yeah
forget that [ __ ] picture show them
the picture that everyone needs to
[ __ ] see show them the picture of the
main bodies that this that this [ __ ]
18 year old was a that greg abbott
allowed him with state law to go buy
that weapon to murder and slaughter and
tear apart those children that's the
pictures you should see of these
children that's the picture you should
see of them
just like emmett till
show them the horror
show them maybe it'll change their
[ __ ] mind probably not some of these
sick bucks like greg abbott and some of
our other boneheads but maybe just maybe
maybe americans will wake up and realize
what the [ __ ] is happening to our
children what the [ __ ] is happening to
our schools what the [ __ ] is happening
to our fellow community members when
they're being shot in churches and
grocery stores i i read a post that
comment the other day
this is how vile this is with with
governors like greg abbott passing some
of these laws
one one of our listeners um commented
somewhere
i no longer
wear flip-flops in a grocery store i
only wear tennis shoes
now you say well why would you do that
the reason why is so she can run
think about that if you're planning out
what shoes you're gonna wear to go buy
milk
think about that for a second folks
putting on the right pair of shoes so
you can run from bullets because you
gotta go buy milk
you crazy [ __ ] who think this
is not a gun problem
she's not right she's not putting on her
shoes to run from a person
she's running from [ __ ] bullets that
are being flung out of a weapon that is
designed to kill people who have flak
jackets on who have body armor on
and they're killing little children
they're killing innocent people in
grocery stores churches and schools you
[ __ ] pieces of garbage and especially
this [ __ ] piece of garbage greg
abbott now i do want to show
the um
the uh
interaction here between beto
and and greg abbott
um you know i do want to say one one one
thing is uh
is the idea of
of showing those photos or showing video
it reminds me when i was in driver's ed
and i don't know if they still do this
but i imagine they still do probably is
when they show you
the people that were driving drunk or
got into a car accident because they
didn't wear a seat belt or whatever it
was right and they show you oh this
person [ __ ] went through the window
or this person was drunk and they got
into a you know uh eight car pileup and
this is the body in their brains spread
out across the [ __ ] uh pavement
those i still remember those images they
are disgusting they are effective as
[ __ ]
right making you remember why you
shouldn't do this because this might
possibly be an outcome for the dumb
decision that you make
well here's the thing and and some
people may say you're crazy you're
absolutely out of your mind to show
people these images there's a story
of an 11 year old girl
in the robb elementary school
who was cowering next to her friend's
dead [ __ ] body
and to make sure that the gunman didn't
shoot her
she pulled
blood
off the dead body of her friend
and smeared it all over her body and
played dead
so that shooter would think she was dead
and would not fire at her an 11 year old
girl
had to [ __ ] take the blood off her
friend's dead body
when moments before they were
happy
right they were getting ready for their
summer break
they were they were probably they were
probably
excited
about memorial day weekend and the plans
that their families had
and she has to take
and smear
the blood
from up her friend another [ __ ] baby
a little bitty baby
person
and spread it all over her [ __ ] body
to play dead it is sad and disgusting i
mean like you know we were talking today
they had two days left
two days left of school those two days i
remember them in grade school those two
days are when you're like helping clean
up the classroom and you're putting away
the desks and the final two days are
just basically like
all right we're just gonna play around
we're gonna go on recess we're gonna do
this we're gonna do that because there's
no there's nothing left to do it's just
kind of clean up and have a fun summer
two days
two [ __ ] days before they were let
out to go run through sprinklers and go
to the pool and and scuff their knees on
the ground
it's [ __ ] gross it's [ __ ] gross
as as gross as uh
the the mayor
of uvalde this [ __ ] guy
he almost if people knew who he was i
was gonna put him on the list absolutely
no one would know who this [ __ ] idiot
is no one should know who this idiot is
i don't even think people in the town
know who this guy is unless they've had
to deal with the [ __ ] probably this
guy barely getting across stage to tell
his
he's a [ __ ] vile piece of [ __ ] but
this is the scene and we actually were
playing this uh press this nra press
conference live um where they're trying
to clean up the mess of what they've
done to children in texas by by allowing
19 students and yuvaldi to be
slaughtered these politicians that are
sitting up here they're there to blame
for this
and beto decides to tell them to do
their [ __ ] jobs uh there's a meme
going around and it says when you order
thoughts and prayers
but do your job show do your [ __ ] job
shows up and it's a picture of beto
pointing at them and the law enforcement
officers pointing for him to get out but
let's listen to this because watch what
greg abbott doesn't do that's the that
is the most speakable moment of this
entire clip is what he doesn't do watch
what he doesn't do
get up
[Music]
is she what he didn't do game did you
notice that there
did you notice he couldn't even look at
betto
what he's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] such a
[ __ ] coward that he wouldn't even
turn and look beto in the eye
forget about saying anything to him no
you're not saying anything to him no no
no no couldn't even turn to look him in
the [ __ ] eye you got ted cruz
saying like oh get out of here with the
father yeah like the guy he the guy oh
my god ted cruz is a cuck okay
also a consideration if he wasn't
already on the list i would have put him
in on alphacut because he stood behind
that table and he's like yo get out of
here don't beat your politicizing this
meanwhile i gotta get my thoughts ready
when i talk about this back door problem
right right right
it is ridiculous and there was jose's
true colors here because he's doing
something even coward more cowardly
tonight he won't cancel
on the nra no no no
because he bought and [ __ ] pay for it
he bought and [ __ ] paid for so he's
gonna phone him in with the [ __ ]
video message what a pile of [ __ ]
[ __ ] i actually think that the video
message is much more cowardly than even
showing up like oh yeah donald trump
what a [ __ ] coward can't even [ __ ]
beto o'rourke approaches him and says do
your [ __ ] job like a goddamn
man gets belly to belly with this guy to
tell him to do his [ __ ] job
and this guy got a phone in on the nra
because he has to say something because
he's bought and paid for but he can't go
there because he's such a [ __ ] no no he
can't show up there actually is
something you reminded me of something
um
is the
is the gym shoes
not wearing flip-flops but switching out
for gym shoes commercial yeah and i
wanted to play the commercial for
everyone um it came out after sandy hook
it was for from the sandy hook promise
which is an organization
and gun violence
um
so let me let me play let me play let's
let's play this real quick and then when
we come back we'll give we'll give the
bone of the week greg abbott his due but
this this should tell you why
greg abbott as governor is a bonehead
and you should vote him the [ __ ] out
this year my mom got me the perfect bag
for back to school
these chemical binders help me stay
organized
these headphones are just what i need
for studying
these new sneakers are just what i need
for the new year
this jacket is a real must-have my
parents got me the skateboard i wanted
it's pretty cool
[Music]
these scissors really come in handy in
our class
these colored pencils too
these new socks
they can be a real lifesaver
[Music]
i finally got my own phone to stay in
touch with my mom
[Music]
[Music]
sandyhookpromise.org with that ad
i don't know how old that is it's
several years old now but um
um if you if you've if you've got
anything to give um at all just a couple
pennies a couple dollars
um don't forget some of these
organizations out there that are working
really hard
that are
in the fight and make politics out of
this issue because it should be politics
it is about policy it's about having
common sense policy in this country to
save our children save our community
members our friends our colleagues lives
from this absolute [ __ ] nonsense that
we have to go through every day in this
country because of [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ] like this
because of greg abbott the bonehead of
the week this [ __ ]
let's give him his due
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well there you have it greg abbott
bonehead of the week bonehead of the
month bonehead of the year whatever you
want to give him him and the rest of the
gop with the blood on their hands
folks i've said it all week you need to
become one issue voters and one issue
only and that is vote them the [ __ ] out
[ __ ] you the gop that is your one issue
[ __ ] the gop [ __ ] em [ __ ] you greg
abbott and [ __ ] anyone who's like you
folks that's the bonehead of the week
it's been a it's been a hard week here
you have a great memorial day weekend
but stick around we have a few
announcements
right after the song
[Music]
[Applause]
well gabe um bonehead of the week um
what an ending um
i tell you
we try to laugh we try to smile and
don't forget to do that this weekend
because um
hold your families tight laugh with them
smile with them chuckle with them
your friends your family your community
members because in this country we never
know when or where
it's going to happen
um so love the [ __ ] out of the people
you love don't let anyone tell you you
can't love who you want to love i don't
know [ __ ] have some sex this weekend too
like they don't want you to have
whatever you want man you want to do it
in the back door doing a bank door like
whatever the [ __ ] you yeah
ted cruz he's always projecting with
banning the back door so you know that's
where you gotta go
that's where you gotta go you gotta go
well it happens it happens gabe but i i
do i do wanna say yeah i mean like kind
of just take this weekend it has been
rough this week has been [ __ ] rough
take this weekend to just relax you know
like i know there's gonna be
a [ __ ] ton
of more news more [ __ ] up news that
comes out of the situation that we learn
about because these incompetent
republicans and police officers didn't
do their job and couldn't prevent what
was preventable and couldn't stop what
they had the power to stop when they had
the opportunity and chance to and even
after the fact they won't do their job
and that's why what tony just said is so
important we need to vote these mother
[ __ ] people out because if they don't
they're gonna send empty thoughts and
prayers they're gonna keep speaking at
their nra conventions and they'll keep
doing whatever they want against the
betterment and best interest
of us as as americans
so they're gonna well i mean they're not
going to stop trying to take your rights
they're not going to try to take your
rights for for safety in schools and
you're right to life in this in this
country they're not pro-lifers they're
pro-starvers they want to starve
children at the border they want to make
sure children are in danger in schools
they want to take away your right to
your body they even want to tell you
that life begins at a boner or before a
bone or maybe just a thought of a boner
it just says
i mean it's masturbation is a sin dude
so
we're talking we're talking before the
masturbation yeah yeah yeah i mean
you're thinking it you can't even you
can't even touch you can't even touch
yourself while you're going to the
bathroom anymore because that just might
be a human life
when you're touching no hands
yourself
so don't touch yourself when you're
going to the bathroom you may just be
waiting i gained a human i did see a
question here that i want to bring up
yeah let's let's do it we got a few
minutes left i'll answer a question
before the friday's over
it was uh from minus margie and she
wants to know will we be here on monday
uh you goddamn right mm-hmm well we i
mean i will be i don't yeah i'll be
there i mean i'm gonna be here baby i'm
gonna be here monday we do not let off
the gas listen monday through friday
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific youtube twitter
twitch and simulcasting from the minus
touch facebook page i don't take
vacations folks
because i want you to hear the [ __ ]
truth and i want you to hear it in a way
that is cathartic but also it gives you
the power and the ammunition to go out
and to fight these fascist [ __ ] and
vote them the [ __ ] out and get your not
just you but your your your friends your
family excited excited about the future
of this country that you can take
control of that you can say i'm
pro-democracy i want common sense
democracy in this country and i'm going
to fight for it i don't care if you're
liberal conservative independent
whatever the [ __ ] you consider yourself
i don't give a [ __ ]
people need to have common goddamn sense
in this country stop this delusional
[ __ ] yeah
and we need to fight for our common
sense democracy so join us we're not
going to be quiet join us we're not
going to back down every single monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
two hours youtube twitter twitch live
go to the minus touch facebook page we
simulcast there subscribe to the youtube
channel also make sure you subscribe to
apple spotify google
we you can download the podcast when
you're on the run if you want to listen
to it
and you and you can't watch the video
you can listen to us on all your
favorite podcast directories
thank you to all the new listeners out
there by the way what comes out tomorrow
and sunday
oh yes well tomorrow we're gonna have
the best of the week where we have we
put together some of our best clips and
then sunday the bone of the week which
you just watched we're going to put it
out on all the directories and the
youtube channel for you to watch it just
alone so go check that out and this i
just put up the super chat graphic
everyone uh sorry we didn't get to
celebrate the super chats today but it
is back on everyone noticed it is back
on i did get the the tony
i fixed it he fixed it i fixed it i
alone can fix it
i don't know i don't know
you have a have a safe and happy
memorial day weekend again
love your family love your friends like
and you know have have have some beers
smoke some cigarettes if you want yeah
this is america i'm not going to smoke i
quit smoking a long time i don't
you know what i'm saying oh yeah
we know what you're saying you know what
you're saying you you you wokers out
there and you mother wokers out there
just cali bro dude just [ __ ] joking
mother wokers
mother wokers midnight tokers you know
that's who we are well uh everyone have
a safe and happy
holiday weekend um have fun love love
your loved ones love your family hold
them close
kisses and hugs and all that kind of
good stuff
until monday because we will be here on
monday like we are every single monday
until then surf's up mother wokers surfs
the [ __ ] up
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules no boundaries i think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking